As we'll see later on, electronic
prescribing or e-prescribing for
short is a key requirement of the new
federal EHR adoption programs.
Because electronic prescriptions
are clear and legible and
an EMR can often spot potential
problems as prescriptions are written.
E-Prescribing has been shown to
dramatically reduce medication errors
within a year of being adopted.
As you can see here they decline from
42.5 per 100 descriptions to 6.6
within a year of this practice, or the
typical practice adopting e-prescribing.
While of course they remain the same
in those practices that continued
to manually prescribe.
Someday soon hopefully, each provider
will have a full medication record,
including whether patients
are filling their prescriptions and
then refilling them at
the proper interval.
Both are currently major problems.
Currently patient privacy concerns, the
topic of lesson four are an impediment
to routinely and automatically
providing this information.